this next story is so toxic in the sense
that it confirms that there's an entire
political movement for whom politics is
just sport and friendships and cronyism
and that nothing about actually helping
people or doing what's good for the
country matters and I'm going to cover
it because it is important but for
different reasons than some of the
headlines are suggesting so Anthony
Scotto Moochie went on CNN yesterday and
breaking news he says he's no longer
supporting re-election for Donald Trump
he's still a Republican he likes Trump's
policies which is just hilarious but
that someone else maybe should run for
the Republican Party in 2020 and I have
to hand it to CNN's John Berman who was
interviewing him Berman exposes that
this is just a personal problem between
scaramouche II and Trump it doesn't
really have anything to do with
scaramouche II now finding Donald
Trump's behavior deplorable which every
normal person should by the way this is
sport and scaramouche's relationship
with Trump has soured now the back story
is scaramouche's a longtime Trump
supporter he was briefly White House
communications director about 10 or 11
days and since being removed from that
role so quickly or resigning he
maintains support for Trump over the
weekend
scaramouche II made some very light
criticisms of Donald Trump's visit to El
Paso which was a horrifying visit I mean
the scaramouche II was wrong in that he
didn't criticize Trump enough quite
frankly and Trump fired back saying
scaramouche she knows nothing about me
and all sorts of other stuff in comes
scaramouche II on CNN and starts to sort
of sound anti Trump Anthony last week
when I asked you if he was still
supported and the answer was yes this
morning when I asked you if you're
calling for a change at the top of the
ticket you said it should be considered
so are you no longer as of this morning
I'm in a neutral I'm now in an I'm a
Republican so I'm not switching parties
to support a Democrat I believe in the
values and the policies of the
Republican Party but I'm I'm now neutral
on the president you're now new
personality to continues to act and if
you now oh absolutely you have to you
have to get into a neutral position and
remember you are no longer an active
minded you are no longer a Anthony I
just I just don't want to pass this by
so people you are no longer an active
supporter of President Trump in his
re-election bid yeah I think that's
I think that's pretty obvious from over
the weekend I mean the guys actually
dissembling a little bit and he's
sounding more and more nonsensical and
you know we're sort of an SSI stew it
and people inside of Washington that's
just President Trump just let him act
like that he's still a terrible person
he still believes in the values of the
Republican Party he still believes in
Donald Trump's policies but he's
changing his tune on Trump but then John
Berman points out and I'm glad that he
does it hold on a second Anthony
nothing has changed as far as Trump all
of the reasons that you are claiming are
the reasons you no longer support Trump
or a backing off of Trump have been the
case forever Trump's language Trump's
tone Trump's handling all of this stuff
the only change is that you and Trump
got into an argument over the weekend on
Twitter and here is how Anthony scary
movie responds I was gonna say so the
one intervening event over the weekend
was you had a Twitter exchange with the
president where he criticized you
directly all the other stuff is stuff
we've seen from President Trump for
years at this point from when he was
before president so so what changed
exactly over the last two days okay so
yeah so so you and Allison have often
asked me that and people say well okay
where's the red line where you you you
you break from your support from
somebody because remember loyalty is
symmetrical it's not a symmetric and so
so what I said to you last week was geez
this is really polarizing this is very
very divisive as a supporter of his I
would caution that we now go in this
direction you brought up stochastic
terrorism in our last interview and I
suggested okay I can understand how this
charged rhetoric coming from the bully
pulpit of the presidency could lead to
some unattended tragic consequences so
that's the reality long story short he's
no longer a supporter of Donald Trump's
reelection big win wow stunning news one
dude who worked for Trump for ten days
no longer supports reelection but the
change isn't really the surprise because
nothing has changed in terms of
scaramouche II isn't against the
politics of Trump he's not really
against the style of Trump or the idiocy
of Trump or anything else or of the
Republican Party this is just what
happens when it's all about your tribe
your buddy who scratches your back
scaramouche II endlessly said in this
interview the policies are great
Republicans are great I'm a Republican
everything's great
no they aren't you're just now mad at
Trump you're feuding and getting
attention and you're no longer
supporting re-election and by the way
him saying he's neutral like he's no
longer a supporter of Trump's reelection
but he's neutral on it neutrality are
you serious neutrality is being
complicit in a case like this and this
is a real difference between the left
and the right last week I told you about
Republicans in Texas trying to cover up
a secret recording of Republicans
talking about a hit list so let me just
remind you what that was in Texas I
believe it was a Republican pack guy
went to the Republican Texas State
Speaker of the House and going from
memory and they recorded a conversation
where they were talking about a hit list
what Republicans do Republicans want to
target in primaries in Texas and the
Texas Republican Party a Texas
Republicans at large and national
Republicans decided after hearing the
tape wow this is really damaging we need
to cover this up and make sure that no
one ever that the tape never sees the
light of day on the Left we would want
that recording out immediately okay if I
found out that there was a recording of
Bernie or Warren or whoever saying
horrible things or of some left-wing
group conspiring to do whatever I want
to know whose toxic I want to know whose
destructive I want the tape out we need
to get these people out of our movement
and move on as soon as possible for the
right it's just sport and this is
another example does Anthony scaramouche
II actually believe that Donald Trump's
policies are good for the United States
like he says maybe maybe he always has
maybe he never did but it's what he's
saying and it's not even really what's
at issue because it's just sport it's
checking boxes it's winning friends
scaramouche II lost a friend and
he's neutral undaunted from being
reelected these are truly sick and
amoral people but that's what makes them
hard to fight we've got to find a way to
do it but it is just sport it's checking
boxes and even when they back off of
supporting a bad candidate or bad ideas
it's rarely actually because of a change
of heart it's some kind of interpersonal
conflict as we're seeing here